-Our first guest tonight
an Emmy Award-winning comedian
in his record-setting 19th
season on "Saturday Night Live."
You can also see him in "Kenan,"
which airs Monday nights
at 8:00 here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-Don't do it.
-Do what?
-Don't you lock me
in this basement again
like when we was kids.
-Man, would I try to do that?
I'm grown.
I'm a grown-ass man now.
-Stop inching towards the steps.
-I ain't inchin' towards
none of them.
Grown man!
-Stop inchin'!
-I don't got to do
nothing you say.
-Gary! Gary!
Ow!
Boy, if I catch you!
-Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Kenan Thompson, everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back, my friend.
Welcome back.
-That was a funny clip.
That was a pretty funny clip.
-Really funny clip.
-I'm proud of that.
-19 years on "SNL."
I feel like "SNL"
is one of those shows,
it maybe gets a little easier
but it never gets easy, right?
-No. I mean, you know,
it's comedy.
I think comedy has to be earned
every single time.
You can't just assume that
everybody's going to laugh,
like now.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I'm saying?
-But now, tell me,
I was wondering,
'cause now this is the second
year of double duty,
where you've done "SNL"
at the same time
you're filming "Kenan."
-Yeah.
-Season 2 of "Kenan,"
you've got a really great cast.
You got Don Johnson.
Chris Redd from the clip.
Fortune Feimster.
What do you think?
Is it like one season
of a sitcom is equal
to like 10 years of "SNL"?
How do you feel in year two?
Do you feel, like,
way more settled?
-It is a lot. It's a very
different experience.
Like "SNL," we can kind of just,
you know,
coast it out a little bit
until Saturday,
you know, because the show is
live, so the only kind of things
that we really do for real
are the pre-tapes on Fridays.
So Monday through Thursday
I'm just in, like,
sweats and,
you know, dirty socks.
[ Laughter ]
But when we shoot, when I show
up on the "Kenan" set,
it's like a 12-hour day,
for sure, guaranteed.
It's like that
Monday through Friday.
So, yeah, it takes a lot,
but at the same time,
it's such a wonderful group of
people, like you just said.
Also Kimrie Lewis
and Taylor Louderman,
and Dani and Dannah,
my little daughters.
It's a just great group
of people.
-So, Dani and Dannah,
who play your daughters,
they are real-life sisters?
-Yeah, real-life sisters.
-And you got started --
Here they are right there.
-Look at -- They're sweethearts.
[ Audience aws ]
Look at their sweet faces.
-And now, you obviously
got started
in this game as a young person.
-Yeah, but not that young,
and imagine to be able to
start your experience
with your sibling.
I think it's such a great story.
-Yeah.
-And they are from Atlanta
as well,
so they are keeping it very real
on the show.
[ Laughter ]
-Was Georgia winning
the national championship,
was that a big deal?
-Bulldogs, yeah.
Shout-out to the Bulldogs!
Where the South at? Bible belt!
-How was your mom with it?
-My mom, she is a big fan but
she's more of an Ohio State fan.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Unfortunately,
she went to Ohio State.
[ Light boos ]
I know, right?
Midwest, nah, no thanks.
-By the way,
if you met Kenan's mom
and you just booed her school...
[ Laughter ]
The sweetest woman!
-She is a very sweet woman.
I didn't know where you were
going with that.
-You were like trying to decide
if you were gonna have my back?
You were like, either
"listen to him" or like --
[ Laughter ]
-"Take it easy, Seth."
Attacking his own audience.
-I thought of you this week.
I mean, I was very happy about
this as a Red Sox fan.
David Ortiz, "Big Papi," got
inducted into the Hall of Fame.
It is, and I mean, a long list,
but this is my favorite
of your impressions.
-Oh, my God, he's saying
"biiig lunch."
That's what he's going to have
to celebrate, a biiig lunch.
Big Papi, yeah.
I love that dude.
-Did you see him
find out the news?
I mean, because the only thing
I'll say is --
-Very casual, like he wasn't
expecting it.
-The great thing about it,
first of all, I loved his shirt.
-Full dinner party.
Yeah, colorful.
-I don't know if the sound
was synced wrong,
because the thing I liked about
it, he was on the phone
with a guy for a really long
time before he celebrated
getting the news,
and it was very clear
where the call was going.
-Also I felt like they all heard
it before he celebrated,
so they were just waiting on him
patiently.
Shout-out to them because they
were very poised.
-I felt like everybody else
in the room was like,
"David, you know
they're saying yes?"
-Also, Cooperstown,
who's calling with something
else, you know?
There's no other news.
-They're like, "Hi, David.
This is Cooperstown.
Are you with people?"
"I am."
He's like, "Uh, maybe go
in the other room."
[ Laughter ]
-"You didn't get it."
"Well, why would you call?"
-How was it having our friend
Will Forte back last week?
-Yes, it was the best.
I mean, and shout-out
to Ariana DeBose.
She did an incredible job
the week before.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But it's always such a pleasure
when our old people
come back
and I can take the week off.
You know what I'm saying?
But, like, Forte had basically
like 80% of the show written
already before he came
through the door,
so it was just incredible.
And then Kristen was back.
It was great to see
Kristen around.
-You have some people
who you impersonate.
You mentioned Big Papi.
You did this this week,
and Stephen Smith saw it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, Michael Irvin.
-You did a Michael Irvin.
This didn't even air.
This just went up online.
-That means Stephen A. Smith
really did it.
That's really cool.
Yeah, me and Chris and Chloe did
their morning show,
so it was me doing Michael Irvin
and Stephen A. was Chris,
and Chloe was -- I don't
remember the lady's name.
"The lady," unfortunately.
[ Laughter ]
-No, that's fine. In this day
and age, that's fine.
-Yeah, there's going to be some
friendly tweets about that
to be answered tonight,
I'm sure.
But, yeah, it's always nice
when people can take
the impersonation in stride,
and they loved it
and they shouted it out,
so it was great.
-You got a shout-out.
-Now I'm Googling
who that lady is.
-Okay, great, and then we can --
-We'll continue to talk.
Go ahead.
-We'll ADR it in later, yeah.
I'll make this question
a long setup.
-"First Take lady."
-So, "Weekend Update"
is a segment,
it's sort of a news parody.
It happens in the middle
of the show.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Colin Jost, Michael Che.
-Yeah, yeah.
Molly Qerim. That's her name.
Yeah, Molly.
So Chloe played Molly.
Shout-out to Molly.
-Thank you. Shout-out to Molly.
We apologize.
So, you guys did
the Village People.
-This was such
a fun "Weekend Update"
because it just
came out of the blue.
I don't think it had anything
to do with, like,
what most of that "Update"
was about that week.
I think it was the anniversary
of the song or something.
-I think it was maybe that Trump
was using it
as his walk-in music.
-That's what it was.
Trump was using it
as his campaign music
without permission,
and they did not like that.
So we did this sketch,
and then I got to get a chance
to meet Victor,
the guy I was playing.
He called and was like --
I think his assistant called,
and was like, "Would you like to
meet Victor?"
I was like, "I'm sorry, who?"
[ Laughter ]
"You remember you did
the Village People yesterday?
And Victor saw it, and he would
like to Zoom with you guys."
I was like, "Of course."
I got Bowen to come.
We were just sitting there
on a Zoom,
which are usually pretty casual,
but Victor's side of the Zoom
was very hoity-toity,
to a point.
I mean, it was just
a sheet curtain background.
[ Laughter ]
It was a lot of anticipation.
"Please hold for Victor."
And then he came into frame,
full helmet and sunglasses
and the whole nine.
I was an immediate --
I could have been in 1975.
-Yeah.
-Running around, having
a good time as a super fan.
But when you see someone that
iconic, I think, actually appear
in real time in front of you,
it's --
-I also shout out to Victor
thinking, "You know what?
I'm going to make this
the best possible situation.
Get me the helmet."
-Yeah, I would love
a signed helmet. So this is it.
Victor, if you would, sign
your helmet, send it to Seth.
He'll get it to me.
Appreciate it. Appreciate that.
-He can have my address
but not yours?
-You'll have Seth's address
and not mine.
No, but he could not have been
nicer about it.
-Well, it only makes sense
for people to be nice to you.
You are the nicest person I know
in show business.
Kenan Thompson, everybody.
"Kenan," Monday nights
at 8:00 here on NBC.
"SNL" is back this week
with host Willem Dafoe,
and musical guest Katy Perry.